[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je baisse la musique pour vous
accueillir dans ce nouvel épisode de mon
village direction le Loir-et-Cher plus
précisément dans la Beauce à Houk ou
plutôt devrais-je dire ou que la
nouvelle puisque depuis 2017 cette
commune a fusionner avec les communes
aux alentours pour s'agrandir et j'ai
regardé dans nos archives la dernière
fois que nous avons mis les pieds dans
cette commune c'était en 2016 il est
vraiment temps pour y retourne
ça voilà magnifique je crois qu'il y a
une vingtaine de producteurs comme prévu
et on voit une place avec l'Église qui
est somptueuse
aujourd'hui alors nous vous voudrez des
saucisses de volaille nous dire sur ce
marché de Hook s'adresse quand même pas
mal de monde non
bourgade qui est assez centrée si vous
regardez sur une carte entre on va dire
Vendôme Blois Châteaudun c'est assez
centré donc c'est un petit marché qui
qui draine quand même beaucoup de gens
aux alentours et marcher du mercredi
matin qui est très agréable et de quoi
on parle au marché ce matin c'est quoi
les les petites news les petites news du
matin c'est surtout le temps le temps
c'est vraiment les news
et puis je prends des frais je poursuis
la découverte de cette commune de
oucques-la-nouvelle nous sommes à la
sortie de la ville et j'ai repéré cette
résidence senior ici des personnes âgées
autonomes qui n'ont pas besoin
d'assistance médicale vivent ensemble en
communauté on va à la rencontre c'est
l'heure du déjeuner
et des tomates avec un peu de maïs
d'accord merci je le fais bonjour
bonjour tout le monde merci de nous
recevoir et je m'installer à cette table
je vois qu'il y a une place de libre ça
fait combien de temps que vous êtes
installés ici
et je peux vous demander votre âge
madame 94 bravo félicitations vous me
dites que c'est votre deuxième famille
ici à ce point là
oui le personnel est agréable agréable
c'est inimaginable on a besoin d'un
petit service on a un souci on peut se
confier
c'est un taxi ambulance on va aller à la
rencontre
bonjour monsieur bonjour madame vous
venez de déposer quelqu'un oui
absolument on vient de un retour de
consultation d'accord est-ce que vous
retourner dans le centre de Hook oui
nous rentrons à l'agence on peut venir
avec vous si vous le souhaitez oui il y
a de la place pour deux personnes devant
comment on fait pour continuer à faire
ce métier depuis autant d'années faut
surtout aimer en effet le métier
d'ambulancier taxi parce que nous avons
les deux casquettes faut aimer porter
secours aux gens être là quand ils ont
besoin j'estime que j'ai un métier à la
demande donc je me dois d'être là quand
les gens ont besoin même si c'est le
dimanche le soir tard le jour de fête
Noël premier de l'an c'est un sacerdoce
et on rentre dans votre boutique qui est
en plein centre-ville
bonjour
France 3 les gens ont des toutes petites
retraites et ne peuvent pas se payer
plusieurs transports comme chez un
kinésithérapeute en transport assis
quand il n'y a pas de prise en charge du
régime général ça coûte cher le
transport quand il y a pas de médecin à
côté d'ophtalmo de spécialistes etc
comment font toutes ces personnes alors
comment font les personnes et bien ils
trouvent plus ou moins de la famille qui
des fois vient de loin qui parfois
prennent leur journée pour emmener leurs
aînés ou alors ne se font pas du tout
soigner
et voilà c'est comme ça que se termine
cet épisode de mon village ici à hook je
vous donne rendez-vous la semaine
prochaine lundi en direction du Loiret
nous allons à Chambon-la-Forêt